when I answered the phone they were like
you apply for the job and I'm like I did
I did
let's see where this goes but I had no I
had no nothing about policing nothing
said when I got arrested when I was
eight fast forward to the end of my
college career the football thing she
was pregnant and she was getting ready
to have our son I'm she was close to
having our son at the time being I had
to make a decision put the eggs on the
counter football and go to something
else cuz I need something more
sustainable I applied for everything in
the City of Tucson I had a degree I got
I got hundreds of knows one day they
called me and it was after an argument
in me in her head obviously so we would
just argue briefly on the phone about
the engagement ring or something like
that it's nothing major and I tell this
story because it's always funny to me
how this happened we had a little
argument the night before wake up the
next morning and I get a phone call from
the Tucson Police Department and
initially I thought she had called
police on me like she was mad at me I'm
like why was she called police on a
basic argument like this you want me to
go to jail but when I answered the phone
they were like you apply for the job and
I'm like I did I did let's see where
this goes but I had no I'd know that
about policing nothing so when I got
arrested when I was eight in the in the
agenda that you feel you know growing up
in the black community feeling like the
cops always have to get you and I did a
ride-along man and it changed my life
officer Sean pain changed my life doing
that all along and that kind of set my
career up so you become a police officer
this is sort of a 180 as you just saw
from from where you started right what
was the most eye-opening thing about
being an officer it was the idea that I
had no idea what police did and I
thought I did right watching cops listen
to people online I realized that people
that have never put on the badge and
actually served as police officer they
have very limited understanding a
policing period I mean there I mean
limited to like 10% of an understanding
even less than that if you know somebody
that's a police you may have a little
more but I had no idea completely a
different world it's completely a
different job than people know about
emotionally legally you know the
training I mean all of that is is
completely different and if
I've got a taste of that even after all
the training my first arrest was where I
was like this is real man this is real I
really have the power to take somebody's
freedom away and this is not a role
player when we call him an Academy where
he's probably speaking to be a criminal
this is a real person we really motions
a real life and they can really kill you
too and that was a that was a pivotal
point in our opening point for me what
was it like did you ever go back to the
old community and the guys that were
giving you the weed as an eight year old
don't know seesaw you're in your uniform
now growing up in Fort Worth I became
right you already were right you were
wearing what there was there was
remnants of that right you had a black
community in Tucson and you arrested
people that look like people that you
grew up with act like people you grew up
with like my cousins and grandma you
know and so dealing with that kind of
give you a little you know flashbacks of
what went on and I got to see it from
both sides all of that horrible stuff I
thought they did to us when we were in a
vacant house how they treated us and all
that stuff I realized that the monsters
was right they did what they supposed to
do getting a call of that nature not
knowing who to expect knowing that we
died on a day to day basis from calls
simply like that and that really you
know made me really really open my
understanding to it yeah
what about racism within the police
department right listen to half the
media you know police departments
they're all racist they're you know
looking for racist ways to incarcerate
yeah it's the biggest load of crap I
ever heard in my life the biggest load
of crap police if people understood what
policing was you honest you would
understand that it's rare for a police
officer to be actually a racist now are
there racist people on a police part yes
there's racist pastors there's ray I
mean come on
we all know we all know that every walk
of life there's some idiot out there
there's still lingering too hateful
rhetoric yeah
but does it drive you crazy that you
have to qualify it always with that it
drives me crazy all the time yes there
are homophobes there are races yeah
there are bad mean people cannot
exterminate all the right dinos could do
it we can you know we can't but some
people need to know that because
watching the media every day
if you're not an informed person or you
don't you're not a person that's a
leader and you can lead with your own
thoughts your follower you'll fall into
that stuff but it's very difficult to be
a racist on a police department and one
of the biggest reasons why is because
you can't you can't pick who you serve
in the least racist people in my opinion
on a white police officer they work in a
black community because you put your
life on the line every day for black
folks you are willing to die for black
folks you have to visually see and feel
the pain and hurt in the community when
brothers getting shot every day people
don't realize that police are the ones
got to put those young brothers and body
bags I don't care who you are when you
see a young man with his brains hanging
out clinging for life maybe even
pleading for his life gurgling and blood
the age of your son the age of your
nephew cousin somebody that looks like
your mom your grandmother a young baby
that's been shot through the head from a
drive-by
I don't care what race you are man it
messes with you in for people to think
that these white officers are these
cruel evil people that don't have any
sense of emotions or attachments of
human life these people are are the
people that are pushing is radical evil
and Liars
you put these young people in body bags
every day you go to their mom
grandmother and you look that lady in
the face trying to hold back your own
tears because you could only imagine
losing your son some of these women have
lost all of their children to gang
violence and you got to look in the eye
and you got to be strong for her and
everybody else and say I'm sorry but
he's never coming back
and that that's what people don't
understand happens and I also believe
that it's racist in my opinion to make
the projection that white officers are
targeting black people in the community
and one of the one of the main reasons
is that you would have to assume that
all black people are bad think about
this for a minute if officers are afraid
of black people that means that all of
them are doing something that will lead
officers to be afraid of them that's not
true it's only a few dummies that are
destroying a community what about Graham
who been robbed they called the police
for help some woman have been raped they
caught a police for help
officers are seeing another side of
black people that they don't want to
tell you about but they project it so
people can be divided and I think that's
the biggest thing that that bothers me
about it so since you were probably
uniquely positioned in Arizona as an
officer to go to some of these
communities and talk to some of these
people do you think you were able to to
wake up some young kids that were up to
no good and in a way that maybe a white
officer just wouldn't have been able to
as well intentioned as he might be I
think young people and black people in
general you know I was considered the
black person whisperer right I'm serious
like we were gone calls and black people
will be like oh you know what I don't
want to talk ma'am what a black officer
man come on brother tell you know tell
them tonight they go to jail just like
they would with the right officers but
somehow they feel compassion because
they felt they can identify with me and
a lot of times they were listening to me
articulate to them brother didn't what
you think it is they pull you over cuz
you cuz you black you think they care
about your color your skin they you got
pulled over cuz you had a suspended
drivers license or suspending
registration stop jump into that
conclusion because you are creating a
scenario of frustration and and conflict
that that need to be had officer just
comes over to you doing a routine what
we call routine traffic stop and that
you you hype how do you put me on
because I'm black this is what that
means to an officer when you say that is
that I'm a racist right and I don't have
any integrity at all and I didn't waste
it all these years developing building
what I've established and you're telling
me that I'm willing to throw that away
and I have no integrity I care about my
family I don't care about my pension or
nothing because I want to racially
profile you as if I'm dead
shallow-minded well you better believe
you probably about to get a ticket you
know and I think people don't understand
it they start to the conversation I'm
very wrong when they do that a lot of
officers let it go but some officers
that you catch on camera sometimes they
don't take you like did you also get the
reverse of that where you go into these
communities and then they'd see you and
be like well this guy's the sellout yeah
why would sometimes sometimes it would
happen more often than not they felt
that they can identify with me one
reason why I think God kind of put an
anointing
me that allowed me to reach people
uniquely black writer and you know or
whatever the fact that I didn't curse on
the job help me reach people uniquely
because when the stuff is hitting the
fan the only person that sounds does if
he got has integrity are not just
integrity but sounds like he's calm just
because I'm not yelling curse words
people attracted me I feel like God gave
me a gift to communicate as well so I
was able to communicate with people and
in you know people talk about a suicide
and all kind of stuff what do you make
of just sort of how the media treats all
of the shootings and that you know
certain shootings if it's a white cop
and a black suspect then we treated a
certain way if it's a black cop and a
white one we treat it differently a lot
of times the same people who are
outraged over it one way then the next
day it happens the other way then they
ignore the scenario the way we're
everyone's playing this really twisted
game policing right now there's money
and black people's emotions right we're
probably the most emotional people a
group of people if you want a group in
the country more twice as many white
people have been shot this year unarmed
and black people in America almost every
year the case is that more white people
get shot unarmed in black people if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell